[Music]
[Applause]
Ron jorski led the Eagles to the NFC
Championship trip to the Super Bowl many
many many years ago and Jaws jaws
already gave us his picks for this
weekend all right so let's see let me
see what jaws has Jaws uh the Ravens
over the Texans by four ners by 18 over
the Packers lions by 10 over the Bucks
and the bills by three over the Chiefs
Let's Make Way for Ron jorski Hey Jaws
how are you Dan great to be with you
appreciate the introduction I did not
like that many many years ago though uh
in the Super Bowl was it too one too
many menis one too many
many okay let me start in your backyard
here with the Eagles Nick sani's future
will be decided
when it's already been decided he should
be the coach of the Philadelphia Eagles
and finish his contract I he's won 34
and lost 17 regular season games in the
playoff three years went to the Super
Bowl yes it was it was an awful finish
of the season but I think the the full
body of worker Nick serani says there
should be no concern about Nick serani
being the next next head coach and stay
as the head coach of the Eagles are they
going to announce this or the fact that
they're not announcing it leads you to
believe that you know there there's
nothing to see here let's move on yeah
you know Jeffrey Lor Hoy Roseman they
they they take these things very very
seriously as to all owners in the NFL uh
but the Eagles have always been very
careful and uh looking at every option
they have uh and and I just got to
believe they believe in in Nick serani I
mean the guy's done a good job Jeffrey
will be very very thoughtful in his
approach to it and I think when he when
he thinks it through there'll be there
will be changes there's no question I
mean the team creater you know the
second half of the Season there will be
changes I don't think it'll be Nick with
Nick serani okay can you pinpoint what
happened here in the last eight games
with this team and you know the loss to
Tampa Bay like is there a singular thing
that you can point your finger to I
don't think there's a singular thing Dan
there's there's kind of a theory that
that that I have I don't know if it's
right wrong or different uh but during
that 10-1 101 start you know the team
was playing good football but they were
barely winning football games a lot of
things went their way and you sometimes
get to believe in yourself that you're
infallible and you just have to show up
and win and the loss of the 49ers the
loss of the Cowboys I think I think Rock
the foundation of of the football team
and they never really regathered from
that they they they all of a sudden
doubt you know got into play you know
you lose to uh Seattle you lose to the
Giants you lose to Arizona and I think
they went in that Tampa game with
serious serious doubt that they were a
quality football team I believe they
were I believe offensively they have as
good as Talent as any team in the
National Football League uh defensively
a lot of injuries and and the defense is
what really hurt them coaching change
from
the coordinators I think at that
mid-season Point hurt them but I still
think the talent level on the team is
very very good but that that's that that
second half of the season was absolutely
it was it was hard to deal with yeah you
know you Chang defensive coordinators
the secondary wasn't very good Jaylen
Herz might have been hurt but I didn't
think he played you know anywhere near
what we saw in the Super Bowl last year
but Nick serani you think is going to
stay as the head coach let me ask you
the um do you think think the Cowboys
reached out to anybody before deciding
that Mike McCarthy was going to be the
head coach I do not uh I I think Jerry
Jones felt very comfortable with Mike
McCarthy and again you look at the full
body of work of Mike McCarthy it's been
very good Jerry Jones has always been
very conscientious about coaches that
he's going to keep you know Jason
Garrett I think was there nine nine and
a half years um he he he doesn't make
knee-jerk decisions I think he's he's he
he is thoughtful as well he wants to win
as much as anybody but all these owners
and all these coach coaches and all
these players they all want to win badly
they're professionals and they they want
to win but I I think
sometimes non-reaction is the best
reaction not a panic move and I think I
I think when when Jerry and his his sons
got together and reviewed where this
team has been maybe over the last decade
or two decades I think they felt at this
point Mike McCarthy was the best choice
to move forward can you see Bill bellich
in
Atlanta I certainly can yeah I think I
think when you look at the Arthur Blank
you know he's he's dying for a winner
you know I mean he's he's been trying
and trying and trying and it just hasn't
worked with some of the kind of I'll say
unknown coaches that that he's hard
maybe didn't have the pedigree of a bill
bich and I think Arthur Blank would be
enamored to bring in you know obviously
the greatest coach of all time you know
so if you could bring that coach to
Atlanta create that buzz and find a
quarterback there's a lot of Talent on
that Atlanta team you find the right
quarterback you know you find your
stoud that team can turn it around real
quick all right let me uh ask you we
have a couple of poll questions here if
I was going to ask you to rank the BET
better story of the four remain four
remaining quarterbacks in the NFC so if
we start with Baker Mayfield and making
it to the Super Bowl not winning the
Super Bowl what what is the best
storyline Jared gof going back to the
Super Bowl Brock pie getting to the
Super Bowl and of course Jordan love the
best story of those four quarterbacks
making the Super Bowl is
who wow they're all they're all great
stories um I I I think you know my my
knee-jerk reaction would be Baker
Mayfield I think CU he had kind of been
thrown to the side of the road as a guy
that was done you know been with a
number of teams and they didn't see
enough in him he gets in a situation
where Todd BS believes in him they he he
had some rough patches during the
regular season he worked his way through
it you know he fought through injuries
late in the season worked his way
through it and I think the game he
played against Eagles on Monday night
was a phenomenal football game but I
think when you look at the history of
Baker Mayfield everyone thought he was a
bust and now he's got a chance to you
know a couple wins away from a Super
Bowl appearance so my kneejerk reaction
to the baker Mayfield is is is a top
story but they're all good stories they
all yeah they really are yeah I would
take Baker Mayfield as well now the AFC
if I said CJ Stroud in his rookie year
is going to go to the Super Bowl uh
Patrick Mahomes going back to the Super
Bowl Josh Allen going to his first Super
Bowl and Lamar Jackson going to his
first Super Bowl best story this easy
this one's CJ Stout he has been
absolutely phenomenal uh a rookie to
play at the level he's playing at I
think is just just remarkable and know
as as you can see over my shoulder here
is my large screen TV not on right now
this is where I watch the the coaches
tape every single week of as many games
I get through and as I've watched stoud
progress to this season it has
absolutely been been fun to watch okay
but what are you seeing jnes when when
you get the coaches film compared to
what we see what do you see with CJ St I
see I see see 11 offense and 11 defense
you see the design of the play and what
the defense is doing to take it away and
what the main thing that I see what
jumps out of me his ability to see the
field he doesn't have tunnel vision when
he breaks the pocket he he's very
expansive in his view of the field he
throws people open they are covered he
sees the void in defense with with
accuracy and anticipation he throws
people open he's Fearless in the pocket
he'll stay in the pocket look down that
gun burle which I think is very very
important in today's NFL because you're
still going to get hit even though the
rules have changed quarterback is still
going to get hit so you need to be
Fearless in the pockets so and his
ability to move outside the pocket and
still keep his eyes downfield and
believe you know we hear that statement
a lot about quarterbacks well his eyes
are downfield well no kidding but it's
amazing some guys break the pocket and
they start looking down and looking for
places to run if you're going to be
effective as a as a movement quarterback
in this league your eyes must be down
the field and still moving as you're
scanning down the field okay what do you
see with Jordan love that we may not
see um a little Aaron Rogers maybe a lot
of Aaron roggers I think there's there's
a part of his game which I I look at him
go oh my God what are you doing know
throwing off balance off his back foot
and it was it was maybe it's the Aaron
Rogers Brett fav approach to playing
quarterback that that stays in Green Bay
but some of the most uncommon throws
you'll see made by those guys and I
think Jordan love has kind of picked it
up from Aaron Rogers and and and the
ability to test himself by what I mean
by that is make those difficult throws
try to make those difficult throws and
then as As you move on in your career
you filter them out you you finally
figure out what you can do and what you
can't do I think was he what he's really
figured out now is what he can do and
forgotten about what he can't do and
doesn't try to do that what do you see
with
momes um how can you not love Patrick
Mahomes I mean the way he plays the game
uh it it just it it drives me crazy
because you know I'm kind of an old
school wonk for mechanics and things
like that and uh he throws that all out
the window you know he he he will not
set his feet he'll throw off balance
he'll throw off platform uh he'll throw
off Rhythm he'll throw off non- Rhythm
but what's it like as a quarterback
though Jaws when you may not have
complete confidence in your
receivers it's horrible what's that
feeling Dan it it's it's horrible you
know when uh when you see receivers
dropping the football you know and and
and you're you're always going to say
the right things the meia ask question
you're always you're always going to
support your guys they're your teammates
they're not trying to drop the football
but deep down in you get that oh my God
oh my God can he make a damn catch you
know I mean and it it it it begins to
deteriorate it honestly I you know I
played 17 years and I can say I've had
receivers that had chronic drops you
know then that happens that's just the
way it is and the only thing you can do
is hug them and hopefully they can work
their way through it but this team I
mean I I believe they had the most drop
balls of any team in the National
Football League this season so as a
quarterback you're probably looking at
those bonuses you may have for
completion percentage so cost your money
as well Dan great to talk to you as
always Jon have fun this weekend thanks
for joining us always do thanks Dan
always a pleasure of being on your show
that's Ron jorski former NFL quarterback
and uh he works the Eagles pre- and
postgame live for NBC Sports
Philadelphia so